georges cusm à norwich présidents de
républiques souveraines bonjour georges
kuzmanovic
merci beaucoup d'être en direct avec
nous sur rtl france la prise de parole
attendu on l'a dit est peut-être ce soir
ou demain avec des mesures probablement
sur la fermeture des écoles avant les
vacances c'est ce que préconisait
notamment valérie pécresse la présidence
de l'ile-de-france
quelle est votre réaction quelles sont
vos attentes de la part d' emmanuel
macron et oui elles sont elles sont
faibles jeu comme je pense comme
beaucoup de français eux
tout le monde a bien conscience que ce
gouvernement à des grandes difficultés à
gérer cette crise et eux qu'ils se sont
surtout des errements il va de charybde
en scylla et que lille s'est mis dans
une situation extrêmement compliquée où
il a le choix entre la peste et le
choléra c'est à dire soit laisser les
écoles ouvertes et avoir une
contamination qui s'aggrave soient tous
fermés et paralyser encore plus
économiquement le pays est déprimé
déprimé le pays allait cela est dû à une
stratégie vaccinale catastrophique en
particulier quand on a comparé à des
pays à d'autres pays en particulier
notre voisin la grande bretagne il ya
aussi les on l'a entendu les les
professeurs qui déplore le manque de
test dans les écoles qui aurait pu être
fait d'avantagé bien plus tôt selon
l'entourage du chef de l'état emmanuel
macron serait devenu un expert en
épidémiologie au point de ne plus suivre
les avis du conseil scientifique et
emmanuel macron se renseignent beaucoup
il attendait les chiffres hier soir
avant de se prononcer le fait de ne plus
suivre ses avis du conseil scientifique
et de laisser la place aux politiques
c'est la bonne marche à suivre selon
vous ces syndromes jupiter si syndrome
de la monarchie
présidentielle particulièrement aggravée
avec monsieur emmanuel macron alors je
suis pas sûr que monsieur emmanuel
macron c'est devenu un aussi bon de
l'épidémiologiste
car n'est rien que dans notre cas
république souveraine il y a maintenant
un an le 15 mars
nous proposions de suivre la stratégie
mise en place par la corée du sud qui
est assez simple qui a été largement
rappelé par les spécialistes et les
vrais épidémiologistes consistant et
bien comme vous l'avez dit a testé
massivement et à isoler les cas les cas
mais vraiment les isoler ceux qui sont
malades et ne pas imposer un compliment
généralisée et tout un pays
et cette situation de terrible dans
laquelle on est depuis un an
pourquoi par exemple la corée du sud a
actuellement moins de 2000 morts pour un
pays qui est tout à fait comparable au
nôtre nous frôlons les 100 mille en
france et ce qu'ils font c'est avoir des
masques avoir une industrie en propre
qui permet de réagir qui permet de mai
de faire des masses comment il fallait
faire des masques faire des respirateurs
moment il fallait faire des respirateurs
et les moyens d'appliquer une cette
logique tester isoler le gouvernement
vous répondra qu'il fait mieux que
certains de ses voisins européens êtes
d'accord dont la france est un des pays
les plus catastrophiques c'est des
calculs de boutique et si c'est ça la
ligne de défense du gouvernement
mais ces terrifiantes et quel mépris
pour nos concitoyens comme comme si on
prend exemple sur les états unis par
exemple nous sommes proches qui sont nos
ailiers officiellement eh bien c'était
très très mal parti et mais c'est un des
pays les plus touchés par contre ils ont
mené une politique vaccinale assez
exceptionnelles massives qui ai commencé
très tôt et ont rapporté à la population
nous risquons de dépasser les etats-unis
qui sont un des pires pays en termes de
mortalité donc vraiment c'est ce serait
une trés c'est au nom qui dit que ce
gouvernement se se targue d'avoir un peu
moins de morts que
dans les pires pays le concernant la
mortalité a vacciné matin midi et soir
on s'en souvient c'était l'appel du chef
de l'état la semaine dernière écoutez ce
qu'en dit le député de la seine-maritime
ces lascars jumelles nées week-end ni
jour férié pour la vaccination qu'il
promettait la semaine dernière le
président qui marche seul abbeville
samedi le centre de vaccination ferment
faute de doses comme on dit dans la
picardie chez l'ami françois ruffin
macron grand prometteur si fait eu
quelques cafouillages dans cette
vaccination maintenant ce sont les
vaccinodromes qui qui sont priorisées il
n'y a plus de vaccins mis en forme a
signé chez les généralistes
il va falloir aller en vaccinodromes
c'est une bonne idée selon vous et c'est
une bonne idée si les choses étaient
organisés et s'il y avait des vaccins le
problème c'est que le gouvernement ne
fait que des effets de manche et
économique au lieu d'agir ce que vient
de dire ce député tout à fait juste je
vous rappelle les cafouillages ont été
très nombreux il y à peine deux semaines
on demandait aux généralistes de prendre
des rendez-vous de vacciner que ils
allaient être les agents premier pour la
vaccination et le dimanche soir ça
c'était un vendredi et plus dimanche
soir on leur envoyait un message qu'il
n'y avait pas assez de vaccins
donc c'est bien les vaccinodromes s'il y
a des s'il ya des vaccins or je crois
que c'est mal parti parce que si l'on
écoute le ministre de la santé allemand
jens panne lui a une vision complètement
différente de la situation en europe et
il a dit clairement publiquement
l'europe
en tout cas l'union européenne
n'arrivera pas à vacciner pour endiguer
ce troisième vague et n'a pas les moyens
en terme de vaccins pour le faire c'est
pour ça que l'allemagne dans gala merkel
s'est proposé d'acheter des vaccins
spoutnik vais même si l'union européenne
refusait de les valider c'est dire que
la situation est mauvaise alors je ne
sais pas par quel miracle tout à coup en
france tout irait bien
c'est un effet de manche et un effet de
communication je crois que
ce gouvernement espère que la volonté
divine fera que les choses iront bien je
voudrais votre réaction georges
kuzmanovic à ces fêtes sauvages qui ont
pu eux encore à lyon hier ou à lille où
la police est intervenue à lille
notamment pour disperser les jeunes
beaucoup s'en indigne de ses images
quelle est votre réaction à vous mais en
plus considéré que will et certains
jeunes ne sont pas sérieux mais mais ça
ça montre une certaine exaspération
également et oui en fait j'avais un
retour sont extrêmement forts n'a fait
donc j'étais comme comme plonger dans la
soirée dans la soirée un petit peu à
distance chez moi sympathique donc il ya
dans ya une exaspération des jeunes
qu'on peut comprendre la situation des
jeunes en particulier psychologique est
extrêmement mauvaise mais tout ça c'est
l'effet encore une fois d'une une
gestion de crise depuis le début qui est
catastrophique et donc le pas entraîné
que des comportement inadéquat
personne n'a autant aucun pays on
organise de confinement comment elle
organise de manière aussi ubuesque dans
quasiment aucun pays le gouvernement n'a
menti à ce point et puis on ne peut pas
toujours porter le blâme sur les jeunes
il me semble qu'il ya des restaurants
clandestins qui sont ouverts qui
fonctionne toujours et où on retrouve et
ces jeunes de ça beaucoup de politique
donc c'est bien de donner de leçons mais
il faut il faudrait d'abord être
exemplaire et puis comment voulez vous
dire qu'il y ait une moralité dans ce
pays quand le numéro deux de la santé
monsieur salomon le professeur sall rond
qui a été pris la main dans le sac par
une commission d' enquête du sénat
montrant sa responsabilité dans le fait
qu'il n'y ait pas assez de masques au
début de crise et qui a demandé à ce que
les documents soient falsifiés auprès
des instances de santé pour burro masqué
sa responsabilité at il démissionné at
il aidé mais été démissionné non bon
donc ce gouvernement se porte la
responsabilité sur sur des gens qui
effectivement non pas le meilleur
comportement entendent en temps de crise
sanitaire
mais voilà on doit d'abord s'occuper du
pays et plus efficacement et ça
éviterait ce genre de catastrophe ou
encore des pv en perspective pour ce
week-end de pâques
c'est ce qu'a promis le ministre de
l'intérieur à partir de demain on là et
on l'a entendu précédemment un gérald
darmanin 5 millions contrôles effectués
par les forces de l'ordre depuis le 15
décembre et au total ce sont 5 123 mille
procès verbaux qui ont été délivrés
c'est ça la politique de restriction
pour lutter contre le coc vite vous êtes
d'accord avec ça on voit combien elle
est inefficace
encore une fois la bonne chose à faire
c'était de mettre en place
alors peut-être ont-ils été surpris au
début mais il ne fait aucun effort pour
le faire de mettre en place un système
de test massif continue et d'isolement
des des malades la propagation de la
maladie est en roue libre et on a ce
sont pas des pv qu'ils vont y faire face
sont des vaccins et notre gouvernement
n'a notre pays n'a pas fait de vaccins
au palier les anglais en faire un vaccin
non mais sérieux je crois que c'est
significatif tout cela 5ème puissance
militaire mondiale la sixième puissance
militaire glaciers puissance économique
et nous n'avons pas produit
notre vaccin ah si il y en a un qui
était produit en à saint-herblain meleka
achetés par les par les ultras les
britanniques parce que ce vaccin est va
passer par les fourches sous les
fourches caudines de l'union européenne
il reste très peu de temps vous êtes
favorable comme vous l'avez évoqué le
ministre de la santé allemand à aller
chercher les vaccins ailleurs sans
passer par l'union européenne mais bien
évidemment si le problème est de
vacciner alors il faut vacciner il ne
faut pas s'en prendre prendre tous les
moyens les cubains qui est un tout petit
pays ont eux aussi produit
un vaccin mais peut-être aurait-il fallu
et faudrait-il que ce gouvernement sorte
de cette idéologie néolibérale qui fait
qu'on va privilégier les intérêts des
multinationales de la forme de la
pharmacie comme pfizer est obligé au
moins forcé l'achat de la licence pour
produire massivement
or ce n'est pas ce qui est fait ce qui
est fait c'est privilégier les intérêts
des grandes entreprises pharmaceutiques
contre les intérêts des de nos
concitoyens merci beaucoup georges
kiejman aux habitudes avoir répondu en
direct à nos questions ce matin sur rtl
france